[Music]
my name is han wai
and i am the creative director and
co-founder of lancervie kny
an award-winning industrial design
studio based between italy and singapore
francesca and i met 14 years ago in
einhoven the netherlands
while we were doing our masters i was
the first batch of design singapore
scholars
and this european experience opened my
eyes and mind to what design can be
can do and can become we've designed for
internationally renowned brands like ms
living divani capellini to name a few
and in 2020 after 10 years in the
business we launched nena
our first chair with the iconic italian
brand zanota
whose pieces are found in museums
worldwide it's an incredible landmark
moment for us
i have lived in the netherlands germany
hong kong shanghai
copenhagen and now i'm based in
singapore how does my life here inspire
me as a creative person
as a designer i grew up in panam valley
and its architecture by tanjing siong
has affected my spatial sensing and
mental navigation
there are many ways to navigate
landscape and many entry points to the
next location
discovery is made fun and engaging
patan valley is a prime example of step
down architecture
where the building stepped down with the
slope side best of all the inherent
variety
in the build forms and building
orientations provide for surprises and
experiences
no one could plan for i love this green
corridor beside my place
because i'm running into nature and its
long straight route
allows me to effectively meditate
minding my breathing
watching where i land my feet
controlling my heart rate
and naturally curating my thoughts when
the green corridor is completed
which i cannot wait for it will be an
uninterrupted 24 kilometer green stretch
between woodlands
in the north and tanjung paga in the
south as a runner
this excites me to the core because it
will be such a scenic and culturally
rich experience to run through heritage
sites and suaves of undisturbed nature
it will be a magical example of
international city plan
that i'm sure will become a main artery
for the burgeoning numbers of bicycle
commuters too
running also helps me experience the
singaporean cityscape
in an entirely different way as opposed
to being a car
bus or train gardens by the bay always
instills a sense of awe in me especially
the cloud forest conservatory
with the 42 meter cloud mountain within
and whose signature supporting
structures i can run under like some
sci-fi futuristic city landscape
which this part of singapore is actually
and has served for backdrops for several
sci-fi tv serials and movies
it makes you realize the senses are not
that great it is a perception thing
and it's actually conquerable it's an
incredibly liberating realization
i love my taco teal especially philipp
saguero
the malia reaction due to the sugars in
the dark soy sauce and noodles
the brightness of the chives and my
goodness
the rich sweet runny yolk flip is a
genius
it's a carbonara thing in chagriday this
is his chakra
this man's an innovator a designer
and i also love natural wines we're
talking about being able to consume and
experience a location
a terroir from another place on earth
you are able to drink a winemaker's
philosophy as well
you are drinking authenticity and truth
straight up
this interior is that of a barcelonian
one easy laid back
you pick your wine off this gorgeous
wall not a wine list
you could start a conversation with a
fellow patron here
the interior is open planned with its
structures and services
intentionally bare the wine glasses have
no stems
you hold the glass more directly and the
food comes on small plates to encourage
tasting
and definitely sharing i'm also huge on
dim sum
because it reminds me of family time on
sundays
the design of the food informs how we
interact
behave feel and make memories
the interior is new southeast asian
chinese
where the design languages of our
culture have been re-interpreted
for the contemporary consumer and their
tastes
the main dining hall chairs are inspired
by archetypal rattan weave chairs
which lends an air of lightness being
transparent
and transparent the concept of life
is a new typology of work play and
living
we're talking about co-working and
co-living all in the same property
the ambiance is casual and energetic a
place where you can bump into people
new or old friends and connect the
public furniture
in life we designed were to encourage
spontaneous fun
as you would encounter your favorite
ride at the playground
the design journey is a marathon not a
sprint
the design process requires solitary and
deep thinking
and running helps me hone my focus but
also the active act of letting
non-essential thoughts go
and just be in the flow of the now the
act of creation
[Music]
a good design process is a mindful
rigorous marathon
running teaches me patience consistency
and resilience
the design journey is a marathon hence i
am a runner
you